[Musique]
présenté lors de la dernière séance
plénière le plan de mandature 2021 2028
est adoptée par l'ensemble des élus de
l'assemblée départementale
la première déclinaison de ce plan et
son budget primitif 2022 qui porte les
grandes orientations de cette mandature
en maîtrisant ses charges
d'administration générale le département
évolué et modernise ses services et
report s'engager au plus près des
réunionnais les élus et les agents du
département auront pour mission
d'appliquer les dispositifs et les
engagements inscrits dans ces huit
grands domaines d'intervention
structurant le budget primitif 2010
le soutien à l'autonomie à tous les âges
de la vie est un engagement fort de la
part de la collectivité
il vise à favoriser les dispositifs du
bien vieillir en faveur des personnes
âgées et handicapées le département
multiplie les dispositifs innovants
comme le financement des visites de
courtoisie des projets d'accueil
innovant d hébergement inclusif hors les
murs et les heures de suppléance de nuit
et de week-end
[Musique]
94,4 millions d'euros sont consacrés à
ces mesures au coeur de la stratégie de
lutte contre la pauvreté accompagner les
bénéficiaires du rsa et renforcer les
mesures d'insertion sociale en leur
faveur c'est l'engagement renouvelé par
la collectivité le département soutient
également l'insertion professionnelle
sous toutes ses formes la collectivité
poursuit son engagement dans le secteur
du logement en soutenant l'accès et le
maintien des ménages fragiles et dans
l'amélioration de l'habitat la
collectivité ambitionne de doubler le
nombre de logements améliorés d'ici à
[Musique]
133 millions d'euros sont consacrés à la
protection de l'enfance et de la famille
avec son programme de prévention des
ruptures familiales et de l'enfance en
danger le département soutient les
dispositifs d'accompagnement comme les
maisons d'enfants caractère social les
services d'action éducative en milieu
ouvert les chèques d'accompagnement
personnalisé la collectivité assure
également le fonctionnement des 41
centres de protection maternelle et
infantile dans les missions principales
sont d'assurer la santé des parents et
de l'enfant de moins de 6 ans le
programme de protection et de garantie
de prise en charge des mineurs confiés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance est également
renforcée
[Musique]
15,6 millions d'euros sont inscrits au
budget primitif 2022 pour la promotion
de la culture des sports un grand
chantier de réhabilitation des sites
culturels du département est lancé des
équipements qui accueille près de deux
cent trente mille visiteurs chaque année
accompagné le monde artistique et
culturelle valoriser le patrimoine sont
les ambitions portées par cette mission
la collectivité soutient la pratique
sportive à tous les niveaux en
accompagnant les clubs les ligues et les
comités
les crédits prévus en 2022 pour
l'épanouissement de la jeunesse s'élève
à 63 5 millions d'euros ils sont
consacrés à l'accompagnement des
soixante mille collégiens en améliorant
leurs conditions d'enseignement et à
l'effort de construction et de
réhabilitation des collèges
l'accompagnement des étudiants en
formation initiale de bac + 1 à bac +5 à
la réunion et en mobilité fait également
partie de ses actions d'accompagnement
vers l'excellence des étudiants
boursiers
[Musique]
47,7 millions d'euros sont engagés pour
soutenir le développement de
l'agriculture et de l'eau les grandes
orientations sont le développement de la
production agricole locale ainsi que sa
diversification
une feuille de route inscrits dans le
plan départemental agrippine 2030
accompagné du plan de transition
écologique et solidaire la réunion doit
préserver ses ressources en étant dans
ces périmètres irrigués et en se
tournant vers une agriculture plus
durable
[Musique]
54,5 millions d'euros sont investis pour
l'entretien ainsi qu'à l'amélioration du
réseau des routes départementales
le département poursuit son engagement
en matière d'aménagement et de
développement au plus près des communes
avec le pacte de solidarité territoriale
deuxième génération
[Musique]
34 millions d'euros financeront
l'environnement le tourisme et
l'aménagement des eaux la collectivité
poursuit son plan un million d'arbres
qui porte un vaste programme de
plantation à grande échelle d'espèces
indigènes et endémiques de la réunion il
s'agira également de diversifier l'offre
éco touristique sur le territoire et
d'améliorer l'accueil du public sur les
espaces naturels
avec ce budget primitif 2022 première
étape du plan de mandature le
département s'engage résolument dans une
transition écologique et solidaire et
dans le développement économique et
social de la réunion dès demain
[Musique]